it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we show you items that could make
your day a little bit better all at
exclusive discounts and during black
black history month we're also sharing
some products from black owned
businesses to start shopping scan the QR
code on your screen right now or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner is here joins us right now how
you doing um well thank you for having
me all right so let's start with these
Wireless yes so raycon Global now Ray J
we all know in the music industry Brandy
sister cousin Snoop so they all come by
it honestly wanted to design audio
equipment for us that was affordable
okay so so many celebrities endorse
different types of headsets they wanted
to actually create them with the best of
the best so starting off with the
earbuds these come in a case where they
actually will charge they get up to 31
hours of charge time through this case
seven hours each time they charge them
when you put them in they have different
sizes so you can use you can make sure
it adjusts you your ear comfortable
amazing sound this audio is top top
notch high quality it has a microphone
in it so you're going to be able to use
these for gaming mobile gaming in
particular phone tablet yeah computer
you're going to be able to use those for
gaming now if you don't mind we'll put
these on okay these headsets these are
amazing these are also for gaming
they've got a retractable microphone on
them this is a high def microphone
amazing surround sound and haptic
vibration so it feels like you're
actually in the game you can feel that
vibration so the audio on this amazing
cbsdeals.com these always go so fast
people love them and the reviews are
amazing the quality with the audio
people love them so right now our
special deal they start at 89.99 that's
25 off and I'll tell you that's less
than half of what I paid for myself
quality headphones you know studio
quality here all right so now we've got
a product for your scalp this is a black
own business tell me about it that's
right so can be this is amazing so
shirelle Sampson actually got her hair
done and realized from the hair that her
scalp was itching and itching and
itching it was making her crazy so she
looked for products out there and
couldn't find any that were clean they
had so many chemicals in them steroids
so she created a serum that's all
natural we're talking about beautiful
things like peppermint oil we're talking
about aloe all the things that really
soothe and comfort the head when you
apply this it gives you a good three
days without any itching so you think
about whether you have hair extensions a
weave maybe just a Sensitive Scalp
you've had your hair colored I'm looking
forward to trying this it's amazing and
the scent is beautiful as well it just
feels magnificent here I'm going to give
you a little bit and then in addition
she's got a hair growth serum give me
your little hand there I'll just put on
your hands
see what it feels like it's lightweight
it's not good I love that and there's
one for hair growth as well she's even
partnered with a cancer center with this
so the products are all beautiful witch
hazel peppermint oil everything that you
would want so right now amazing starting
off at just 10.74 40 off so oh wow a lot
of us have that itch it's through in the
winter it's amazing yeah okay so what's
going on here happy wax I love this
company but they realized that people
really have memories that are inspired
by smell they use smell to relax calm
themselves down maybe invigorate
themselves well these cute little bears
are actually called wax melts we take
them we place them right inside and you
can see how these little bears are
starting to melt right when they melt
you get that flame free scent throughout
your house it is all soy so there's
nothing icky and then look at this when
you're done it's a silicone base it just
pops right out yep so you don't have any
issues with that doesn't smell amazing
so lavender all different types of
scents starting off at just ten dollars
and 47 cents what a great are you
kidding me this is ten dollars amazing
just starting off with our little bears
there but all these different scents
they just really bring it out in your
home and it's all natural bag yes
go ahead and grab that one that's the
Weekender I'm gonna grab this one what I
love about these bags actually the
designer used to report on a different
fashion and design she went to London
she went to Paris she studied design and
then she decided to create a whole line
of vegan leather bags very easy so this
tote in particular was actually on
Oprah's favorite list it's beautiful the
Napa tote and then this one is the
crocodile tote how much is that 47 do I
have that right starting off at 47.
that Weekender it's enough room to
travel with Elizabeth Werner thank you
so much thank you so much of course
partnering with all these companies to
get these deals you can buy anything
that you saw scan a QR code on your
screen right now or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping right now
this is very nice